you write that you work on developing
conceptual Frameworks for understanding
unconventional cognition so the kind of
thing we've been talking about I just
like the term unconventional cognition
and you want to figure out how to detect
study and communicate with a thing
you've already mentioned a few examples
but what is unconventional cognition is
it as simply as everything else outside
of what we Define usually as cognition
cognitive science the stuff going on
between our ears or is there some deeper
way to get at the fundamentals of
what is cognition
yeah I think like uh and and if I'm
certainly not the only person who works
in unconvention unconventional um
cognition so it's the term used yeah
that's one that so I've coined a number
of weird terms but that's not one of
mine like that that's an existing thing
so so for example somebody like Andy
adamasky who um I don't know if you've
if you've had him on if you haven't you
should he's a he's a he's a you know
very interesting guy he's a computer
scientist and he does unconventional
cognition and Sly molds and all kinds of
weird
um he's a real weird weird cat really
interesting anyway so so that's on you
know there's a bunch of terms that I've
come up with but that's not one of mine
so I think like many terms that one is
is really defined by the times meaning
that unconventional cognitive things
that are unconventional cognition today
are not going to be considered
unconventional cognition at some point
uh it's one of those it's one of those
things and so
it's you know it's it's it's this it's
this really deep question of how do you
recognize communicate with
um um classify cognition when you cannot
rely on the typical Milestones right so
so typical
um you know again if you stick with the
with the uh the history of life on earth
like these these exact model systems you
would say ah here's a particular
structure of the brain and this one has
fewer of those and this one has a bigger
frontal cortex and this one right so
these are these are landmarks that that
we're that we're used to and and it
allows us to make very um kind of Rapid
judgments about things but if you can't
rely on that either because you're
looking at a synthetic thing or or an
engineered thing or an alien thing then
what do you do right how do you and so
and so that's what I'm really interested
I'm interested in mind in all of its
possible implementations not just the
obvious ones that we know from from
looking at brains here on Earth
whenever I think about something like
unconventional cognition I think about
cellular automata I'm just captivated by
the beauty of the thing
the fact that from simple little
uh objects you can create some such
beautiful complexity that very quickly
you forget about the individual objects
and you see the things that it creates
as its own organisms that blows my mind
every time like honestly
I could full time just
eat mushrooms and watch cellular time
don't you have to do mushrooms uh just
just sell your automata it feels like I
mean from the engineering perspective I
love
when a very simple system captures
something really powerful because then
you can study that system to understand
something fundamental about complexity
about life on Earth